Pete Buddha judge finds himself under
attack as the wine cave candidate Joe
Biden demonstrates durability and Amy
Klobuchar throws all of the binders I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why have you not gotten a VPN
yet visit expressvpn comm slash Ben so
last night big Democrat debate and the
first 45 minutes of the debate nothing
happened the first 45 minutes of the
debate everybody sort of padded each
other on the back they had this group
hug and then things got a little spicy
so here is the very very short summary
of how this thing went not a great night
for people who to judge
mmm yeah he had his moments but not a
great probably the worst night for
people to judge he's had so far really
bad night for Elizabeth Warren so some
people are giving Warren more credit
than she deserves here Warren had a bad
night Bernie Sanders is always Bernie
Sanders Joe Biden is always Joe Biden
and Amy claw pitch are forced everybody
else to eat salad with the with a comb
so that it was actually a pretty good
night for Amy kelabra charged so let's
just jump right in to this debate
because the big winner
as always whenever we have a democratic
internal debate is president Trump
there's a swing state poll out today
that shows that in the swing states
Biden is tied with Trump that he leads
Trump does every other Democratic
candidate who was on that stage last
night there is a reason for this and
that is that Democrats continue to give
President Trump campaign commercials we
haven't even seen Trump weaponize all of
the contents that Democrats have given
him in the past several months and
there's a lot of it I mean a lot of it
so this whole thing starts off this
whole debate starts off and again they
were down to only seven candidates who
are on the stage
Tom Steyer is not a real candidate and
Andrew yang was provided his typical two
minutes and 30 seconds to talk and say
that he's gonna give everybody $1,000 in
all of us but they're really five
candidates on the stage five serious
candidates for the presidency Amy
Klobuchar is only considered a serious
candidate one because she's a senator
and two because she's running at about
7% in Iowa so you could see the
possibility of a late surge by Amy
Klobuchar if for example she starts to
draw away support from Peabody Judge
which is exactly why she went after blue
T judge last night Buddha judge was by
far the most attacked candidate on the
stage Joe Biden sort of stood off to the
side so did Bernie Sanders and they
watched the kids clock each other by
kids I mean a 70 year old senator for me
and a 37 year old newbie from South Bend
Indiana and Amy Klobuchar who let's be
honest you wouldn't want to meet Amy
Klobuchar in the dark alley considering
all of the the stories that have been
written about her and her apparently
sadistic tendencies in any case this
thing starts with everybody talking
about impeachment because impeachment is
the order of the day and don't worry
we'll get to impeachment a little bit
later on in the show Nancy Pelosi by the
way has a new strategy on impeachment
and that is we're not going to give the
charges to the Senate which is the
dumbest strategy of all time in fact one
of the Democrats key witnesses in their
House Judiciary Committee hearing was a
harvard law professor and that harvard
law professor has now said that same
professor has now suggested that if you
do not actually submit the articles of
impeachment to the Senate then Trump has
not been impeached technically speaking
so Trump can continue to claim he has
not been impeached until they actually
submit the articles to the Senate
according to Noah Feldman who is the
harvard law professor Democrats called
during their House Judiciary Committee
hearing so self-owned from Nancy Pelosi
right there in any case this thing
starts and everybody is talking
impeachment and the angles that the
various candidates took on impeachment
is indicative of their sort of angles in
the campaign generally so Joe Biden's
angle on impeachment is that it's his
job to restore integrity to the
presidency here his job slowly looked a
little bit livelier last night has
Geritol was ready to go you know we need
to restore the integrity of the
presidency of the office of the
presidency and it's about time we get
that underway my job and I think the job
of all of us up here is to in fact well
that's not true some are going to be
actually voting in the Senate but my job
is to just go out and make the case why
he doesn't deserve to be President in
itíd states for another four years okay
so basically I'm here I'm Joe you know
me right his case for impeachment is
really his case for being president and
that is that he is a tree stump and
wouldn't you like a tree stump as
opposed to this wild orange man over
here that's always been try Biden's case
for the presidents he's back to normal
see case then there was Bernie Sanders
his case and that is that Donald Trump
it's not that he is a wild crazy person
it's really that he's not a socialist
so here's Bernie Sanders making his
pitch for the presidency on the basis of
impeachment I believe that I will
personally
be doing this in the coming weeks and
months is making the case that we have a
president who has sold out the working
families of this country for once to cut
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
after he promised he would not do that
and who has documented lis lied
thousands of times since he is president
so just wondering has President Trump
restructured Social Security Medicare
Medicaid because I'm pretty sure that I
would have noticed if he had by the way
all of the talk about President Trump
and and selling out the working class
jobs have been increased under President
Trump in every single state in America
according to new polling data from CNN
76% of Americans say that current
economic conditions are good sixty-eight
percent say that they are confident that
economic conditions will be good a year
from now which would be after the
election so good luck with you hold the
economy sucks case cuz that ain't gonna
fly
we're gonna get to more of the
democratic debate in just one minute
first it's that time of the year you're
buying a lot of stuff right this is the
year when you just blow out those credit
card bills well instead of spending as
much as you as you would be spending
without those promo codes that you can
find online you should be using honey
honey is this wonderful app you put it
on your computer runs in the background
of your computer every time you shop it
finds the best promo codes for you so
you're saving money virtually every time
you shop I've probably saved thousands
of dollars at this point through honey
it works on all the major shopping sites
whether you're shopping for watches as
I'm apt to do or whether you are
shopping for anything else via
amazon.com honey works everywhere honey
has found it's over 10 million members
over a billion dollars in savings it's a
free browser extension that
automatically finds the best promo codes
whenever you shop online honey has over
a hundred thousand five-star reviews on
the Google Chrome store it doesn't make
any sense not to use honey you should be
using honey because why the hell would
you not it'll save you money if you're
buying gifts this holiday season you
need honey if you're not you probably
know somebody who is so do the mussalam
and tell them about honey because I mean
exit what there's no downside it's free
to use it installs in just two clicks
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash Ben again that's join honey calm
slash Ben wants more join honey calm
slash man okay back to this debate so
they're talking impeachment and they are
trying to
make the case for why they ought to be
President based on impeachment Elizabeth
was so we've already heard from Biden
and it's I'm a tree stump and Bernie I'm
a communist and now I hear from
Elizabeth Warren that she's an
anti-corruption fighter an
anti-corruption fighter net as we will
see she has the worst debate of anybody
of the night it was a terrible terrible
debate for Elizabeth Warren I know
conventional wisdom is that she sort of
held steady false she completely
collapsed it was really really bad for
her because her entire stick has been
that she is fighting corruption that is
her entire deal is that she is fighting
corruption here she is making that case
we'll see later on in the debate people
who to judge clocks were one good and
she goes flying through the wall
here's Elizabeth Horne you know this
president has made corruption originally
his argument that he would drain the
swamp and yet he came to Washington
broke that promise and has done
everything he can for the wealthy and
the well-connected from tax breaks to
ambassador ships see she's an
anti-corruption fighter and this is her
shtick there's only one problem it's not
true it's not true
every rule that she has set for herself
as a candidate she has already broken as
a candidate in Prior election cycles and
this is something Budi judge was gonna
bring up okay now to people who judge
she's been searching in Iowa he's been
searching in New Hampshire he never had
great national numbers but that early
state momentum has been very solid for
people who to judge and so his pitch has
basically been I'm Obama but instead of
being the first black president I'd be
the first gay president sure I don't
have any real qualifications to be the
president of the United States sure I've
been like the mayor of a town with 8,000
votes remember he won his election in
South Bend Indiana with 8,000 votes this
will come up later on in the debate as
well 8,000 votes is fewer votes than I
get in a typical Twitter poll when I
just put a poll on Twitter I will get
many more than 8,000 votes okay this is
it's it's amazing this person is
considered a national candidate based on
his record he's very good at this he's a
talented politician
here he is channeling Obama hope hope
and range open drink here's the good
news it's up to us no matter what
happens in the Senate it is up to us in
2020 this is our chance to refuse to be
taken in by the helplessness to refuse
and reject the cynicism so again
channeling the Obama
two minutes um as it turns out people
judge you can only fly above the fray
for so long
the only good answer on impeachment by
the way was given by my boy Andrew yang
he had a moment later on in the debate I
didn't like very much but this was a
very good moment for Andrew yay and
being a real human being saying listen
you keep talking about Trump keep
talking about impeachment the real
problems of the country have nothing to
do with Trump the more we act like
Donald Trump is the cause of all of our
problems the more Americans lose trust
that we can actually see what's going on
in our communities and solve those
problems what we have to do is we have
to stop being obsessed over impeachment
which unfortunately strikes many
Americans like a ball game where you
know what the score is going to be and
start actually digging in and solving
the problems that god Donald Trump
elected in the first place I mean this
is an actual smart answer from Andrew
yang the problem is of course Andrew
yang is not one of the top contenders
okay then they move on to the economy
and this is a real problem for the
Democrats it's a problem for the
Democrats because as I've said the poll
numbers on the economy are very very
strong for President Trump so Joe Biden
is asked by one of the moderators so
Americans kind of like this economy
because the economy is real good they
may not like Trump but what about people
who say they don't love Trump but they
love the economy and Biden says well no
no I just refuse to accept that people
like the economy yeah good luck with
this argument well I don't think they
really do like the economy go back and
talk to the old neighbors in the
middle-class neighborhood you grew up in
no class is getting killed the middle
class is getting crushed and the working
class has no way up it's a consequence
of that and the idea that we're growing
feeling about this we don't have to
listen to the rest him because he says
that then who to judge that and more and
says that it's always the economy isn't
really good sure you feel like the
economy is good but cuz you don't know
in your heart you know the economy is
bad record stock market record low
unemployment in the black community in
the Hispanic community among women like
everyone but apparently it's very very
bad and then you have Bernie Sanders who
does his usual crazy routine
he actually said and this is such a lie
he said this in like every debate and
it's always a lie he says today in
America we have the highest rate of
childhood poverty of almost any major
country on earth of any major country on
earth we have the highest rate of
childhood poverty has he heard of most
of the world has he heard of like
anywhere else other than the United
States cuz that is bat bleep lunacy that
is
just entre okay so the Democrats are
completely disconnected on economics how
do you know they're completely
disconnected on economics because you
end up with Elizabeth Warren saying
things like this so so Judy Woodruff
asks Elizabeth Warren how do you answer
top economists that say that these hacks
are not gonna be good listen to
Elizabeth Warren's crazy answer how do
you answer top economists who say taxes
of this magnitude would stifle growth
and investment oh they're just wrong oh
well if non-economists elizabeth warren
says that huge enormous taxes won't hurt
I totally believe her I totally believe
her we're just gonna completely rewrite
basic econ 101 because Elizabeth Warren
says oh they're just wrong they're just
wrong you know like taking trillions of
dollars out of the US economy and
pouring it down the rat hole that his
government is not gonna hurt the economy
in any way because she says that that's
wrong that it's not true yeah yeah good
again I don't think that most Americans
believe this and this is why Buddha
judge so basically the story of Buddha
judges night is that he kept owning
Elizabeth Warren over and over he just
kept destroying Elizabeth Warren over
and over and then Amy claw I would
come in from the wings like Macho Man
Randy Savage and just piledrive him
who's very amusing
here's people who judge though owning
Elizabeth Warren on taxes yes we must
deliver big ideas and yes taxes on
wealthy individuals and on corporations
are going to have to go up we can also
be smart about the promises we're making
make sure they're promises that we can
keep without the kind of taxation that
economists tell us could hurt the
economy on issue after issue we've got
to break out of the Washington mindset
that measures the bigness of an idea by
how many trillions of dollars it adds to
the budget or the boldness of an idea by
how many fellow Americans it can
antagonize okay that is true it's why
Buddha jej is seeing an upswell okay
that one sentence where he says we've
got to break out of the Washington
mindset that measures the bigness of an
idea like how many trillions of dollars
had adds to the budget that could come
from a Republican debate I mean that
could come from any Republican on any
stage anywhere and he's the only person
who will say that remaining in the
democratic debate and that is why he at
least has some level of popularity
people who judge as we will see he also
while clocking Elizabeth Warren got
absolutely destroyed and just wrecked by
Amy Klobuchar I will get to that in just
one moment first let's talk about that
end-of-the-year to-do list so we are
approaching the end of the year it's
that holiday season the last thing you
want to be thinking about is death is
your own demise well good news you don't
have to think about it for that long
just go to policy genius.com get your
life insurance taken care of if you
haven't done this already it's not
responsible you should make sure that
your family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
and find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred dollars or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home in auto insurance disability
insurance now being a good person this
holiday season means taking care of your
family getting the insurance you need is
one of the great ways to do that if you
need life insurance you aren't sure
where to start why not starting at
policy genius.com
it only takes a few minutes to find the
right life insurance policy apply and
cross another thing off your to-do list
policy genius when it comes to life
insurance it is nice and important to
get it right make sure that your family
is taken care of because otherwise
you're not being a responsible human go
check them out at policy genius.com
again that's policy genius.com and make
sure that you are doing all the hard
work you need to do to make sure your
family's taken care of then just cross
it off that holiday to-do list and you
never have to think about it again which
is a creating pretty good thing to do
when you're talking about life insurance
and death okay so then the democrats get
into their wildest proposals their
wildest proposals always come in the
area of climate change joe biden cuts in
an ad for donald trump in this in this
debate that will be replayed 1,000 times
if joe biden is the nominee Tim Alberta
who's one of the moderators who
apparently apparently he ran into flak
from PBS because he works at Politico
now but he once used to write for
National Review and this is very very
bad now they're a bunch of top-line
reporters who used to write for National
Review like Eliana Johnson was a
top-line reporter for I believe the
Washington Post very nice gal she used
to work for National Review Tim Alberta
used to work for National Review
apparently this is very bad he's the
only person asking intelligent questions
on the stage he says to Joe Biden so how
many jobs you willing to sacrifice on
the on the altar of climate change here
and Joe Biden is like all of them as
president would you be willing to
sacrifice
some of that growth even knowing
potentially that it could displace
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
blue-collar workers in the interest of
transitioning to that greener economy
the answer is yes the answer is yes
because the opportunity the opportunity
for those workers in transition to high
paying jobs tom said is real we're the
only country in all has ever taking
great great crises and turning to the
enormous opportunities
nothing says enormous opportunity like
laying off hundreds of thousands of
blue-collar workers I mean that is one
hell of it and you think that won't be
in every commercial that he that he will
displace hundreds of thousands of
blue-collar workers the answer is yes ye
Joe Biden not a great general election
move now it may help him in primaries
but that general that is going to come
back to harm him then of course you got
Bernie Sanders just being a crazy person
because this is Bert Bernie said the
fact that Bernie Sanders is even a
remotely leading candidate in the
Democratic Party it really says a lot
about the current state of the
Democratic Party they have lost their
minds here is Bernie Sanders explaining
that we should take our entire defense
budget and we should spend it on
fighting the Sun here is Bernie Sanders
the United States has got to lead the
world and maybe just maybe instead of
spending 1.8 trillion a year globally on
weapons of destruction maybe an American
president ie Bernie Sanders can lead the
world instead of spending money to kill
each other
maybe we pool our resources and fight
our common enemy which is climate change
we're gonna get the Chinese to stop
spending money on their weaponry and
instead spend money on climate change
we're gonna get the Russians to abandon
all of the military spending and instead
we're going to spend it and climate
change how we're gonna do that
you're gonna elect me I'm crazy so crazy
I'm just gonna walk in to G's in thing
I'm gonna say you want a piece of this
I'm a crazy man have you seen these
hands I'm nuts
these hands are deadly weapons look at
them they move without my own permission
do you want to be on the wrong side of
the set okay Bernie okay the one of my
favorite climate change responses from
Elizabeth Warren so she openly
acknowledges the
to lower carbon emissions you have to
use a nuclear power and then she
immediately announces that you will
never build a new nuclear power plant so
she is utterly unserious this obviously
but that is Elizabeth Warren in a
nutshell her dishonesty is ranked as we
will see it comes back to bite Rhino I'm
previewing that a lot but it really came
back to bite her last night here's
Elizabeth Warren explaining sure we need
nuclear power but I'm not building any
of it so I see it right now is we've got
to get the carbon we've got to stop
putting more carbon into the air we've
got to get the carbon out of the air and
out of the water and that means that we
need to keep some of our nuclear in
place
I will not build more nuclear oh so you
need nuclear because you need less
carbon emissions but also we're not
gonna build any more nuclear power
plants very serious person Elizabeth
Warren with many proposals and plans I
have been informed by a reliable people
okay Joe Biden did have a couple of good
moments I thought about this is Biden's
best debate by a fairly long shot this
was his best moment so he was talking
about somebody asked him whether he was
naive to believe that he could work
across the aisle because Elizabeth
Warren has said this she said that he's
just naive to believe he can work with
Republicans and here was Joe Biden's
answer there's actually quite a good
answer I refuse to accept the notion as
some on this stage do that we can never
never get to a place where we have
cooperation again if that's the case
we're dead as a country we need to be
able to reach consensus and if anyone
has reason to be angry with the
Republicans and not want to cooperate
its me the way they've attacked me my
son to my family we have to be able to
get things done and when we can't
convince them we go out and beat them
like we did in the 2018 election in red
states and in purpose states hey that
was biting the best answer because the
other Democrats are on the stage going
well could the road much struggle with
these people we're going to line them up
against the wall and then vines like no
we got to work with them and listen I
don't love them but we got to work with
this is actually Biden's best appeal and
many of the Democrats don't actually
understand this appeal the only
candidates on stage making this appeal
are three Biden booted reg Klobuchar are
those are the only ones on the stage who
are making that appeal and it's actually
a fairly smart appeal and then we get
into the race section of the debate and
here's where all the intersectional
glory of the Democrats
comes out now listen you know I love my
boy Android gang you know Andrew I think
Andrew yang is a good guy I think he's a
solid dude I disagree with him on a lot
of politics but I think that he's an
honest fellow I thought that this huh
this answer last night from Andrew yang
was his first dishonest answer in the
entire election cycle so Andrew yang is
asked about the fact that he's the only
person of minority status on the stage I
mean Buddha judges gay but but the only
person of color on the stage is what
yang is asked and here is Yang's answer
and I thought again the fact that this
is sort of the requisite pandering on
the Democratic stage says a lot about
their view of America
here's Andrew yang explaining that he
feels bad that he's the only minority on
the stage by the way just quick note for
the intersectional activists Asians
don't count as part of the
intersectional college and they're too
successful and too highly educated which
is why they don't care that Asian
students are being barred from Harvard
University and a disproportionate level
in order to make room for other quote
unquote less fortunate minorities here's
Andrew yang it's both an honor and
disappointment to be the lone candidate
of color on the stage tonight
I miss Kemal I miss Corey though I think
Corey I'll be back okay that's just not
true I'm sorry Andrew yang is not
sitting around a neckline I miss my
friends it's not like empty tables at
the end of lame is he's not sitting
around and being like where are you he's
not sitting around going Cory Booker I
need where's where's mr. Potatohead in
his angry eyes I need them on the stage
taking up time I need them here where
are they he's not disappointing again
care okay like no one cares they're bad
candidates that's the reason they're not
on the stage again I'm amused and
bemused by the fact that the Democratic
Party seems to have forgotten that
Barack Obama was president for eight
years okay as though they have to keep
proving their bona fide ease every
single election cycle well you know if
we don't have enough minorities on this
stage clearly we've reverted to Jim Crow
style racism alternatively Cory Booker
is an awful candidate Kamala Harris is
even worse but the fact that they have
to keep pandering is just ridiculous
ridiculous and pandering didn't stop
there yet Bernie Bernie Sanders doing
the same routine saying that that if
there if there aren't any of our
african-american brothers and sisters up
here to speak about an economy in which
black people are exploited than I an old
Jewish white man will do it and then you
had Amy Klobuchar
suggesting that she's gonna stop
gerrymandering and
black people are being barred from
voting okay all of that was nonsense but
that's the requisite part of the
democratic debate in just a second we're
gonna get to the Democrats on foreign
policy back to the delusional for the
Democrats in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that it's no fun to
go to the drugstore and look for all of
the materials you need for the bathroom
okay I tend to be very lazy when I'm not
doing this show and what that means is
that I never go to the drugstore and
pick up the materials that I need the
first time I realize that I don't have a
razor and then I need one it's exactly
what I need to use it
okay well the way that I have solved
this problem is I use Dollar Shave Club
because they just ship it to me I never
have to think about it ever again
and their products are better than the
stuff that I'm getting at the store and
I don't have to spend an hour sifting
through all the various products trying
to find the best product that best fits
my Dollar Shave Club has it all Dollar
Shave Club has spent years developing
crafting and refining everything they
have everything I use to look feel and
smell my best I've been at Dollar Shave
Club member for years and not only do I
enjoy the razors for right here on the
neck but I also enjoy their their amber
lavender body cleanser they've got great
stuff for your hair that they just have
everything that you could possibly need
they've got you covered head to toe they
have everything you need to shower shave
style your hair brush your teeth and yes
they even have the world-famous butt
wipes the Dollar Shave Club can keep you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use you get what you want whenever
you need it whether that's once a month
or a few times a year again I love being
able to sort of program this in and just
forget about it it makes my life
incredibly easy and it means that I am
never out of the products that I need
right now you can put the quality of
Dollar Shave club's products to the test
their ultimate shave starter set has
basically everything you need for that
amazing shave the executive razor the
shave butter the prep scrub the post
shave do the best part is you can try it
for just five bucks after that the
restock box chips regular sized products
at regular prices get your ultimate
starter set for just $5 at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash men again
dollarshaveclub.com slash men go check
them out right now it's fantastic and
makes your life easy and the products
are fantastic dollarshaveclub.com slash
pen for the special deal okay back to
the democratic debate so then the
democrats get into the foreign policy
arena and they start off with israel
Bernie Sanders is so awful on Israel it
is almost impossible to under two to
overestimate how bad he is on Israel
because he will always surpass her
expectations so Bernie Sanders has asked
about Israel and he played
the I'm super pro-israel card yes his
entire campaign is staffed by people who
hate Israel he campaigns with Linda
Sarsour he's been endorsed by open
anti-semites Hanauma and Rasheeda Talib
but don't worry guys he loves Israel
listen to this statement he makes about
Israel apparently Israel exists where
there's no such thing as terrorism
Palestinian terrorist groups do not run
the Gaza Strip and the West Bank and
everything is hunky-dory it's just those
weird Jews right it's just those weird
Israelis and their weird weirdness
here's Bernie Sanders saying the real
problem in the Middle East is Bibi
Netanyahu he may have neglected you know
the intervening 60 years of Israeli
existence where its neighbors attempted
to destroy it before Benjamin Netanyahu
became prime minister he may be
neglecting the fact that even Benjamin
Netanyahu's political opponents actually
agree with him on foreign policy but
it's very convenient for Bernie to blame
everything on Israel because he is of
course a far leftist who actually does
not like is really actually despises
Israel Israel has and I say this is
somebody who lived in Israel as a kid
proudly Jewish Israel has the right not
only to exist but to exist in peace and
security
but what what u.s. foreign policy
must be about is not just being
pro-israel we must be pro palestinian as
well and whether in my view we must
understand that right now in israel we
have leadership under netanyahu who as
recently as you know been in dieded for
bribery who in my view is a racist what
we need is a level playing field in
terms of the middle east which addresses
the terrible crisis in Gaza where 60 or
70 percent of the young people are
unemployed yeah because the terrorist
group runs the Gaza Strip but his
solution is that we should be dumping
hundreds of millions of dollars into the
Gaza Strip so those terrorist groups can
continue to conduct terror by the way
the convenient Judaism of Bernie Sanders
is something to behold
the man has nothing to say about Jewish
identity for nearly his entire 80 years
on planet Earth but the moment it is
convenient for him to cite his Jewish
identity in order to bash the Jewish
state then he's all up in it right he is
he is a perfect case
of somebody who's only Jewish when
convenient they can stuff it with this
whole I'm Jewish therefore I have
capacity to speak on this nonsense
nonsense if the only reason that you're
citing your Jewishness is she can
pretend to be a minority or so that you
can claim that Israel is very very bad
and like you're gonna have to name for
me another time when Bernie Sanders has
ever talked about Judaism in a serious
way yeah sure and then you have people
who to judge who sort of glossed over
the question and and he ripped on Trump
and suggested that Trump is actually an
anti-semite because he welcomes
quote-unquote white nationalists into
the White House yeah that was just silly
and then and then you had Joe Biden
Biden at least is living in something
resembling the real world like he's
wrong on Israel but at least he
recognizes you have to keep giving them
physical aids they can maintain their
security but it really is when you get
to China then it becomes obvious that
the Democrats don't know what they are
what they are talking about the only
person who had a good answer on China is
Andrew yang
hey Andrew Yang actually understands a
lot of the challenges that America is
facing with regard to China his take on
China and their technological war on the
United States it's exactly right here's
Andrew yang with our leading
technologist and they say they cannot
match the Chinese resources China just
produced its first major smartphone that
does not have Google Apps and it is now
trying to export its technology to the
rest of the world what we have to do is
build an international coalition to set
technology standards and then you can
bring the Chinese to the table in a very
real way because this is their top
priority and this is where we need to
out-compete them and win
okay so Yang is right about this he's
the only person who had anything
credible to say about this the rest of
them are like I'll be mean to China sure
okay yeah right I mean okay so most of
the debate so far has basically been
everybody hugging each other right it
was more of a town-hall than a debate
but then came what we've all been
waiting for the Rock'em Sock'em robots
the Rock'em Sock'em robots so we started
getting questions about age and about
qualification and it got kind of fun so
this began with Tim Alberta asking Vice
President Biden about his age he says
let's face it dude you're old like your
soups oh really old and Joe Biden
proceeds to act and old just to follow
up Vice President Biden if elected if
elected you would turn 82 at the end of
your first term you'd be the oldest
president American history are you
Churchill are you willing to commit
American history Americans yes are you
willing to commit tonight to running for
a second term if you're elected next
however no I'm not willing to commit one
way or another here's the deal I'm not
even elected one term yet and let's see
where we are
let's see what happens okay and
everybody last at this because everybody
recognizes that dude is real old so and
not a horrible moment for Biden but it
is kind of funny
that he's trying to prove that he's not
old and then he cites British history as
opposed to American history okay then we
get to more let's get to the the dicey
exchanges let's get to the dicey
exchanges so I've been pitching this one
all day the moment when it became clear
to everyone that Elizabeth Warren is the
worst the worst so Elizabeth Warren and
people to judge go at it she starts off
by attacking people who judge for using
bumblers and for using and for
fundraising from billionaires and people
who judges ready for this attack because
Elizabeth Warren has been trotting this
out on the campaign trail for weeks now
and boot each edge is a person who does
his homework right bootie judge for all
of his flaws as as a candidate and all
of his I would say nastiness as a
religious person and all of all this
kind of stuff for all of that P Budaj
edge is a man who does his homework and
so Elizabeth Warren comes after him and
suggests that he is in the pocket of big
donors and Peabody jej just knocks her
through a wall and it is phenomenal
because she has had this coming for a
long time politically she has had this
coming because she has been doing the
I'm on my high horse over here fighting
corruption and this is a lady who has
violated every rule every rule that she
currently says that she holds to she's
violated in the past and Buddha judge
calls her out on it and it's quite ugly
for her now it's not scot-free for
Buddha judge because she does get one
line on him and that line was the most
quoted line of the debate you're gonna
hear the phrase wine cave here the
reason that it's the most quoted is
because of course most of us have never
heard of a wine came what the hell's a
wine cave is it like a place that that
back in caveman days they used to go and
just like guzzle grapes and what
apparently it's something that very very
wealthy people have I'm not a wine
drinker so I don't know much about it in
any case here is Warren and Buddha judge
going at each other Warren gets the most
memorable line but Buddha judge just
finishes her
the stage we have people who can cook
down $5,000 for a check drown out the
voices of everyone else the way we're
gonna win is to bring everybody to our
side in this fight if that means that
you're a grad student digging deep to go
online to Pete for america.com
and chip in ten bucks that's great and
if you can drop a thousand dollars
without blinking that's great too we
need everybody's help in this fight so
the mayor just recently had a fundraiser
that was held in a wine cave full of
crystals and served $900 a bottle wine
um think about who comes to that he had
promised that every fundraiser he would
do would be open door but this one was
closed door we made the decision many
years ago that rich people in
smoke-filled rooms would not pick the
next president of the United States
billionaires and wine caves should not
pick the next president of the United
States mr. mayor your response you know
according to Forbes magazine
I am the literally the only person on
this stage who's not a millionaire or a
billionaire so if this is the problem
with issuing purity tests you cannot
yourself pass
if I pledged never to be in the company
of a progressive Democratic donor I
couldn't be up here senator your net
worth is 100 times mine I do not sell
access to my time
I don't do call time millionaires and
billionaires
I don't need behind closed doors with
big dollar donors senator your
presidential campaign right now as we
speak is funded in part by money you
transferred having raised it at those
exact same big-ticket fundraisers you
now denounced did it corrupt you senator
of course not so to denounce the same
kind of fundraising guidelines that
President Obama went by that speaker
Pelosi goes by that you yourself went by
until not long ago in order to build the
Democratic Party and build a campaign
ready for the fight of our lives
these purity tests shrink the stakes of
the most important election okay so that
is Elizabeth Warren going up against the
king and you best not miss and she meant
Suze not a good luck now then why in
came single stick so it's not a complete
miss to be fair to Warren it's not a
complete miss but it doesn't help her
because he clocked her there right for
him to point out that she has taken
billionaire money and then she took that
money and then she immediately funneled
into her presidential campaign all the
leftovers from her Senate campaign that
is 100% true it is 100% true
and the former governor of Pennsylvania
ed Rendell wrote an entire piece about
this criticizing her for setting these
sorts of false purity tests so frankly
good for people who judge for fighting
back on that particular score now as
well see Budaj edge then it up then
ended up getting kicked around a so it
didn't end up great for Budaj edge
either but at that moment in that
exchange Warren got really hurt because
she is deeply dishonest and that is
obvious to anyone who's been watching
this campaign and we'll get some more of
this in just one second so listen this
holiday season you're gonna be sending
and receiving an enormous number of
packages that means people are coming to
your door almost constantly and you
don't know who these people are you know
one of the things that people who want
to rob your house do is they will rob
they won't they won't knock on the door
or they'll ring the doorbell see if you
are home and then if you're not home
that's when they break in well one of
the things that you can do to prevent
this from happening the best thing you
can do is to use ring ring helps you
stay connected to your home from
anywhere
so if there's a package delivery or a
surprise visitor will get an alert
you'll be able to see here and speak to
them all from your phone if you're on
the go this season whether it's across
town or across the country you can check
in anytime for some much-needed holiday
peace of mind we use ring products all
over our house really makes us feel much
more secure makes me feel more secure
makes my wife feel more secure as a
listener you have a special holiday
offer on a ring welcome kit available
right now with a ring video doorbell in
a chime Pro the ring welcome kit has
everything you need to keep an eye on
home no matter what this holiday season
brings with ring you're always at home
so just go to ring calm /bin again
that's ring calm /bin go check them out
right now ring calm /ban additional
terms may apply you're gonna feel a lot
safer once you got those ring devices on
your house ring calm /bin go check them
out right now okay in just a second
we'll get to pee Buddha jej getting
slapped so he slaps Elizabeth Warren and
then like it the Battle of the
Lilliputians the the slapping between
the the small human beings on stage in
terms of their moral and political
stature continues we'll get to that
momentarily first it is that glorious
time of the week when I give a shout out
to a daily wire subscriber today it's
Derrick Riley on Twitter who's clearly
doing a fantastic job of the most
important role of his life in the
picture Derrick's adorable baby daughter
is wearing a cozy with a cozy winter
onesie while snuggling a glorious left
his tears tumbler has all good babies
should she will grow up big and strong
and brilliant the caption reads she's
two months today growing bigger and
stronger thanks in part to the leftist
cheers tumbler even more nourishing than
breast milk leftist ears amazing and
with the amount of leftist years on the
horizon during this election year she'll
be growing by leaps and bounds
thanks for the pic Derrick and congrats
to you and your family on this amazing
baby okay also if you're not already a
subscriber you're missing out head on
over to daily wire.com slash subscribe
for as little as 10 bucks a month you
get our articles had free access to all
of our live broadcasts our full show
library select bonus content our
exclusive daily wire app which is in
fact a fantastic feature if you haven't
checked it out yet we spent time and
money on it you'll enjoy it if you
choose the new All Access plan you get
that all of that plus the legendary
leftist ears tumblr that you saw that
baby snuggling just moments ago and our
brand-new ask me anything a style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers special guests
on a weekly basis so stop depriving
yourself come join the fun we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so Buddha judge crushes illusion
Elizabeth Warren in that exchange my
pointing out that she's dishonest the
beneficiary of that is Bernie Sanders so
Bernie Sanders immediately responds and
he sort of knocks Joe Biden but he
really goes after booty judging the
difference between Bernie Sanders and
Lauren is that Bernie is an actual true
believer but Bernie's not biessing this
stuff like he's full of it and he's
awful
and he believes terrible things but
Bernie is a true believer I mean that is
a man will set himself on fire for his
cause or at least buy himself a third
lake house for his clothes here's Bernie
Sanders explaining the peabody judge has
in fact taking money from billionaires
my good friend joe and he is a good
friend he's received contributions from
40 for building a nest Pete on the other
hand he's trailing Pete you only got 39
billionaires contributing so Pete we
look forward to you I know you're an
energetic guy in a competitive guard to
see if you could take on Joe on that
issue okay so that that is a brutal hit
by the way Sanders had a good night
because Sanders actually was more upbeat
I think he feels like he's doing well in
the polls because he is and he felt like
he was in a good mood the entire night
he dropped a few jokes here and there it
was actually a good night for Sanders
we're gonna talk about the people who
won the night Biden won the night
Sanders won the night club a try had a
good night why don't I say Chloe Chara
had a good night because she laid the
hardest-hit on mayor Pete I mean this is
a brutal brutal hit on mayor Pete I'm
talking here about clip 33 so Amy
Klobuchar is talking about experience
and she points out that there are a lot
of people on the stage who have some
experience and people who do judges not
one of those humans here is Amy
Klobuchar Buddha judge tries to get out
of it he's prepped for the answer the
problem is he was not prepped for the
response because goodness gracious I
mean she just from the top roll baby
clover jar ago when we were in the last
debate mayor you basically bought the
hundred years of experience on the stage
I just think you should respect our
experience when you look at how you
he actually did denigrate my experience
senator and it was before the break and
I was gonna let it go because we got
bigger fish to fry here but you know I
don't think we had a bigger fish to fry
than picking a president of the United
States we should have someone heading up
this ticket that is actually won and
been able to show that they can gather
the support that you talk about of
moderate Republicans and independents as
well as the fired up Democratic base and
not just done at once I have done it
three times I know that if you just go
by vote totals maybe what goes on in my
city seem small to you she want to talk
about the capacity to win try putting
together a coalition to bring you back
to office with 80% of the vote as a gay
dude in Mike Pence's Indiana that would
be one thing you tried and you lost by
20 points Buddha gently oneis corner he
finally plays the Mike Pence's of bigots
he's a bigot is that this is always
Buddha judges move of desperation so
every candidate has a move of
desperation every candidate has the go
to the well move for Elizabeth Warren
it's I'm not corrupt like you I'm not
corrupt like you and for Bernie Sanders
it's whose billion that's not the worst
people that just those people and for
Joe Biden it's malarkey malarkey and for
Peabody Jed's Mike Pence is the worst
now I don't know what it like did Mike
Pence like hide under his bed once with
a butcher knife or something like Mike
Pence by all available public records
has been nothing but genteel to Pete
Buddha judge when Buddha judge came out
of the closet Mike Pence is like happy
for him hope he leaves a happy life when
Buddha judge joined the military Mike
Pence personally called him up on the
telephone to thank him for his service
and yet people who to judge has set this
whole thing up like Mike Pence vicious
anti-gay bigot standing outside my house
burning crosses and Mike Pence and so
he's a cloaca terms like well you've
never won anything right you want 8,000
votes in South Bend Indiana which again
like I'm an event down here in South
Florida there me like five
and people just at this event and then
8,000 votes is nothing it's a it's a
rounding error when you talk about
national politics you're talking about a
national election that is going to
involve at minimum a hundred and thirty
million voters and you're saying that
because you once won eight thousand
votes in South Bend Indiana a
historically blue city that you are
somehow qualified to win and corbett
chart points that out and and will judge
goes to that safe and happy place which
is I'm gay and Mike Pence hates gay
people and corporate charters like um
well if you're gonna say that you built
a coalition as mayor of South Bend
Indiana
you might wanna remember that eating
like we're gonna ignore this but you ran
for state treasurer in Indiana so you
tried to run statewide in Indiana and
you got cleaned like a fish you got
gutted by the way he didn't lose by 20
in Indiana Mike people do judge didn't
lose by 20 in us a treasure race he lost
by 25 to Richard Murdoch who went on to
sit in Senate and then lose to a
Democrat so it wasn't even like he was
losing to the best candidate it's just
that people who judge his actual agenda
when looked at by people in the middle
of the country is not anything like what
he is campaigning nationally as and koba
chart just finishes him right there I
mean that that's a bad look and quit
which are by the way has a level of
support in Iowa it's not tremendous but
you are gonna see a bump for Amy
Klobuchar in the aftermath of this
debate she had a good aggressive debate
finally when the stage was cleared off
of all the riffraff and by that it just
mean like everybody who's getting 2% or
less once the stage was cleared off and
you had you know people who are actually
getting 5% or more in any state poll
then you could actually see the contrast
between the candidates and you see that
quobba chart actually has the record the
people who judge pretends that he has
that Amy Klobuchar has the positions
that people who judge presents that he
has and so I would not be surprised to
see Buddha judge start to wane now I
wouldn't be something like people are
saying I don't how much the debates
gonna matter it's gonna matter some and
I think that the image of people to
judge as fresh-faced that only last so
long as people failed to recognize that
people who judge has never won an
election that is larger than a thimble
and who's elected class president in
third grade basically in terms of
national politics that's not a rip on
South Bend that's a that's a statistical
reality and Kovich are pointing that out
it's not gonna help him the wine cave
thing is not going to help him it's
gonna look like he is a grasping person
who's attempting to grab
as much wealth as he can from a variety
of people because he doesn't actually
have a base outside of upper white
upper-class white establishment Aryan
types so while he hurt Warren and he did
because she is incredibly dishonest
she's already hurting right she was
already on the downslope Buddha jitters
on the upslope I think you're gonna see
that stall out now I think the very
least you're gonna see him even out I
think that you may see him start to
decline and I think you're gonna see a
little bit of a bump for Amy Klobuchar
specifically because of all of this now
the finest moments of the debate in
terms are just wild leftism and this is
where President Trump makes his money
right and President Trump makes his hey
where the Democrats radicalism woods the
best part is when you get to transgender
politics so again the panda bear just is
the imaginary spirit animal of every
Democrat and so you ended up with the
bizarre spectacle of Bernie Sanders
explaining that he is going to wipe out
discrimination against transgender
communities apparently by waving his
hands wildly and yelling we need a
president who will do everything humanly
possible to end all forms of
discrimination against the transgender
community against the African American
community against the Latino community
and against all minorities in this
country I like how he adds that little
blanket statement on the end all
minorities he started running out of but
he's very gonna miss somebody was like
an Oscar speech where you miss your
agent yeah I have to make every minority
I can think of right now folk gay people
transgender people bisexual little
people african-americans Latinos Native
Americans not Jews did not
intersectional not Asians are not
intersectional and the other minority
design missed all of them like of the
minorities them but Sanders pales in
comparison to Elizabeth Warren again
it's so dishonest so awful here's
Elizabeth Warren I mean you wanna she is
there's die hard and then there's pander
hard I mean this is pander hard with a
vengeance here is here is Elizabeth
Warren explaining what she's gonna do
for the transgender community and this
is just I mean she you know what she is
that there was talk about President
Trump back in 2016 that he spoke
conservatism as a foreign language that
he's sort of approximated where he
thought
and that's why he ended up saying things
like we want to put women who have
abortions in jail and everybody who's
pro-life was like wow not so much it's
because Trump was sort of estimating
where he thought the constituents were
Elizabeth Warren treats the base of the
Democratic Party like they're idiots she
treats them like they're idiots
and so listen to her pandering to the
transgender to transgender Americans the
way that she does this is so overt and
blatant and stupid it boggles the mind
here's Elizabeth Warren here's a promise
I make I will go to the Rose Garden once
every year to read the names of
transgender women of people of color who
have been killed in the past year I will
make sure that we read their names so
that as a nation we are forced to
address the particular vulnerability on
homelessness I will change the rules now
that put people in prison based on their
birth sex identification rather than
their current identification I will do
everything I can to make sure that we
are in America that leaves no one behind
so you know she's gonna do for you
transgender people if you get merged
she's gonna mention her name in the Rose
Garden speech aren't you excited
I bumped she's not pandering that's how
deeply she feels things just like she
feels abortion so deeply she's gonna
wear a scarf a scarf hmm
how this lady rose to near the top of
the of the Democratic Party is is beyond
me okay so it is a weak field there was
one good moment for Joe Biden that I
think is going to be a memorable moment
for Joe Biden Joe Biden was talking
about how he helps stuttering kids on
the campaign trail this became a
particularly memorable moment for Joe
Biden specifically because Sarah
Huckabee Sanders promptly stepped
directly on a rake because she doesn't
understand the Joe Biden was once a kid
who stuttered and has struggled with
that here was Joe Biden saying this
Sarah Huckabee Sanders then tweeted
something to ask you out about it and
Biden really smacked her and that was a
good moment for Biden politically
speaking
here's Biden talking about this my wife
and I have a call list of somewhere
between twenty and a hundred people that
we call at least every week or every
month to tell them I'm here I've given
them my private phone number they keep
in touch with me a little kid who says
III III III I can't I can't talk
what do I do I have scores of these
young women and men who I keep in
contact with hey and and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders didn't understand what he was
talking about there and so she tried to
make fun of him yeah he said I haven't
absolutely no idea what Biden is talking
about and he immediately tweeted back at
her and he said I've worked my whole
life to overcome a stutter it's my great
honor to mentor kids who have
experienced the same it's called empathy
looking up Huckabee Sanders then deleted
the tweet and apologized obviously
because she she said I actually didn't
know that about you that's commendable I
apologize should have made my point
respectfully that's a good moment for
Biden because anytime you do something I
mean that's that's a clear win for him
okay so final analysis Biden is fine
he's durable Sanders has that durable
base Budi judge got hurt last night Club
a chart got a leg up on some people last
night and Elizabeth Warren I think is
done I think Elizabeth Warren is on a
serious downslope right here and it's
only going to continue okay time for
some things that I like and then some
things that I hate so it is a rare day
when I think that Trevor Noah is right
about something so Trevor Noah on Comedy
Central he was pointing out that every
Democrat on stage does this routine or
they're like I'm not rich I'm not rich
I'm not rich I'm not rich as though this
is some sort of qualifier to be
President of the United States and Noah
drops a pretty funny line here here he
is senator your net worth is 100 times
mine Oh Pete Budaj is just called
Elizabeth Warren a wealthy person you
realize for progressive white people
that's like being called the n-word
they're like how dare you call me
wealthy I'm living comfortably okay
and you could see lizard Warren wasn't
liking that because she did that thing
that white women do when someone fights
with then they just face forward like
I'm not hearing anything see Trevor no
Academy fun do and he decides not to be
a partisan hack so that that's that it's
true it's so true and it's been one of
my pet peeves in this whole in this
whole shebang
is is how it is that people judges like
my qualification is that I'm poor right
well guess what they're like millions of
other people who have not earned a lot
of money in Americans so you're 37 let's
be real about this dude you went into
politics after working at Mackenzie
you're gonna be rich if anybody thinks
the people who to judge by the time he
is 50 is not gonna be worth millions of
dollars it's because you're an idiot
people who judge will be worth plenty of
money even Bernie Sanders a lifelong
useless person is worth a million
dollars because he's 80 okay so like
come on come on okay time for a quick
thing that I hate okay so this is an
insane story are you prepared for a
story rife with insanity here you go
this is a story about a woman named Maya
forest and it made a lot of news
yesterday because JK Rowling got
involved we'll get to that in a second
so Maya Forrest adder is a researcher on
taxes she's a tax expert
she works for something called the
center for global development or rather
she did it's a think tank based in
London and Washington the campaigns
against poverty according to the UK
independent she was accused of using
offensive and exclusionary language on
Twitter what did she say that was so
offensive an exclusionary this is a
direct quote men cannot change into
women
offensive and exclusionary to point out
men cannot magically change into women
now I know you and I think about this
and we're like right okay so but in
Britain this is basically illegal as she
said men cannot change into women she
was fired and then she sued she said
that she was protected under the 2010
Equality Act because there are protected
philosophical beliefs under the 2010
Equality Act he can't be fired for
politics for example so what did the
judge decide so the judge at the central
London Employment Tribunal which is
whenever you use tribunal here that just
sounds like something out of the Spanish
Inquisition and it turns out it is
except the leftist
second-lowest Spanish Inquisition judge
at James Taylor not the singer decided
at forest adders view was quote
incompatible with human dignity and
fundamental rights of others so men
cannot magically become women is
incompatible with human dignity and the
fundamental rights of others see it
seems to me that a fundamental right of
another person would be to speak freely
also compatibility with human dignity
seems to be like not firing people for
saying basic biological truths like that
but no according to this judge it is
incompatible with human dignity and the
fundamental rights of others to say a
biological fact according to the judge
he says the tax expert was not entitled
to ignore the legal rights of
transgender people and quote the
enormous pain that can be caused by
misgendering a person so you're not
entitled did you say a biological fact
if it hurts someone's feelings in
Britain if you do that you can be fired
from your job
in Britain and by the way this will move
into the realm of hate speech and pretty
soon you'll be able to be prosecuted in
Britain for a quote unquote misgendering
people already in New York City by the
way the New York City Human Rights
Commission ruled like four years ago
that if a business regularly quote
unquote miss generous people he can be
fine like a quarter million dollars for
each incident which is total insanity so
if you if a man comes into your bar and
you're like hey dude and he's like I'm a
woman you're like are you though he can
sue you and the Human Rights Commission
in New York will find you a quarter
million dollars hey this is this is
where we stand in in cities in the unit
and by the way it's a brute basic
violation of the First Amendment but in
Britain it's even worse this judge's
ruling is fully insane you ready for
this he concluded quote if a person has
transitioned from male to female and has
a gender recognition certificate that
person is legally a woman that is not
something this forced adder is entitled
to ignore miss for status position is
that even if a trans woman has a GRC she
cannot honestly describe herself as a
woman that belief is not worthy of
respect in a democratic society that
belief is not worthy of respect in a
democratic society I mean the utter
unbelievable gall to say that it is not
worthy of respect in a democratic
society to say that a document from the
government does not magically change you
from one section to the other this is
under absolute bat bleep lunacy its
utter lunacy totally crazy any that is
are you kidding me so according to the
government this is what happens when
government gets too big and too
audacious and believes it can do magic
so according to this judge the
government issues a certificate it says
you are now a woman this means that
everyone is now legally obligated to
call you a woman because the government
said so do you have any idea how nuts
that is you know you talk about legal
positivism this is legal positivism
taken to its extreme legal positivism is
the philosophy that rights and realities
don't exist absent the government
stating them ok this is basically like
suggesting that you know for hundreds of
years black people were considered
property in the United States the
government legally considered them
property so if you said that black
person is a person that presumably
because the government had already
weighed in on it the belief would not be
worthy of respecting the democratic side
very offensive to slaveholders this is
nuts
the judge says even paying due regard to
the qualified right to freedom of
expression people cannot expect to be
protected if their core belief involves
violating others dignity and creating an
intimidating hostile degrading
humiliating or offensive environment for
them due regard to the qualified freedom
of expression um you haven't paid any
regard to the qualified right to freedom
of expression it doesn't matter to you
you cannot expect to be protected if
your core belief not even the expression
the belief involves violating other
people's dignity by the way we disagree
with each other all the time in public
life we do it all the time and in
private life we disagree with each other
all the time is every disagreement about
the nature of the world somehow a
violation of others dignity because if
so the government is violating this
lady's dignity by saying she can be
fired for believing a biological fact ok
so why does this become such a major
issue one it's a major issue on its own
to JK Rowling weighs in now JK Rowling
is the author of the Harry Potter series
she is way on the Left I mean so much on
the left that every so often she read
she retcons a character I had suddenly
Dumbledore just becomes game for no
reason it's a children's book but you
know Dumbledore he was always into them
into the lads that was always Dumble the
worst thing but ten years after the
books are written okay
sure why not okay well now she tweeted
out in favor of this right she said
dress however you please call yourself
whatever you like sleep with anything
something adults will have you okay so
far we are in pure leftist progressive
territory live your best life in peace
and security but force women out of
their jobs for stating that sex is real
hashtag I stand with Maya hashtag this
is not a drill this led to the world
collapsing in on JK Rowling she'll
comfort herself with over 500 million
books sold voxcom headlined I kid you
not
JK Rowling's latest tweet seems like
transphobic BS her fans are heartbroken
are heartbroken
JK Rowling just ruined Harry Potter
Merry Christmas
did I miss the part where Harry Potter
was like a transgender tract
also if a muggle declares himself a
wizard are they a wizard are they still
a muggle I'm confused
it was not just the the idiots at box
and their explanatory journalism it was
also the Washington Post JK Rowling is
from internet culture analysis by Sonia
Rao and Abbie ol Heiser they put two of
their finest on this over at the
Washington Post
JK Rowling tried to make her work more
inclusive then she tweeted support for
an anti trans researcher oh there goes
the inclusivity there it goes
that's terrible and evil and wrong
absolute stupidity absolute stupidity
Elena Darcy a Harry Potter who for five
years wrote for the website muggle met
and co-produced a podcast on Rowling's
fantastic B series told the post via
email until this moment I was in a sort
of denial I'm so heartbroken this is who
she's choosing to be the Harry Potter
Alliance a fan led nonprofit distance
itself from Rowling sweet we know that
trans women are women trans men are men
non-binary people are non-binary also
men are women women are men and
non-binary people have no gender that
affirming and respecting people's gender
is kind loving and literally saving
lives this is utterly crazy utterly
crazy well it seems to me that JK
Rowling only has one way out of this and
she has to declare Dobby a transsexual
it's the only way Dobby is now a
transgender a transgender elf Dobby used
to be female but now is male
Dobby could be non-binary you don't know
Bobby's never self-identified so we
could just do this
maybe Harry's a female have you ever
thought about that maybe the series is
so woke that Harry is actually if
had you had that ever occurred to you it
could happen
just wait until next week when JK
Rowling has to walk this thing back and
Sochi retcons a transgender character
into one of her books all of this is
insane and stupid but that is our
society alrighty we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content including the mailbag so if your
subscriber you don't want to tune in you
have two access to the two hours anyway
so you may as well tune in and hear if
your question gets read otherwise we'll
see you after vacation because guess
what guys I am on holiday vacation next
week I will be back the week after so
we'll bring you all the updates head
good news Congress is out of session not
much is gonna happen so you won't miss
you much but if you miss me you can go
tune into our best of shows and you can
browse all of our old con so we have
lots of great stuff and tune in later
today for two hours of additional
content remember daily wire comm slash
gift if you want to get that gift
subscription 25% off until January 1st
otherwise we'll see you next year so
Merry Christmas Happy New Year Happy
Chanukah to everybody catch you around
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is by
Jeff while alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wired production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]